CNN Biden's comments about pandemic
widen Public Health split over how U.S
should respond to covid-19 I love this
they say even as the U.S prepares for a
potential winter surge of covid-19
President Biden roamed the cavernous
Halls of the Detroit Auto Show for an
interview on cbs's 60 Minutes and
gesturing to the mostly massless
attendees told the nation the pandemic
is over we still have a problem with
covid we're still doing a lot of work on
it he told Scott Pelley but the pandemic
is over he repeated let's give a round
of applause to everybody yeah it's all
over everybody everybody can go home or
or leave your home because the
pandemic's over it's so crazy to me they
hear to hear this and then you know I go
out and I still see people wearing masks
in places that don't require them yeah
they must not know that the pandemic's
over yet maybe maybe they needed this
maybe maybe now Joe Biden's sweet
Whispers will uh wage their fears it
will a lot of people wait unfortunately
or for better for worse they wait for
the official word and this is the most
official word you're gonna get anything
Biden says is the top official in the
United States well I wouldn't worry
about what the top official says since
last year they were saying that there
was going to be a severe winter of
illness and death and they were
absolutely wrong about it I was on this
show last year and I said kovid's over
it's it's done with there's no way you
could return I was looking at the data I
was looking at the graphs and and that
absolutely happened all the restrictions
and when I mean coven when I mean this
kind of uh Health mandates and these
emergency issues all of that made
absolutely no sense and we have slowly
seen them dwindle because everything
that they promised that was going to
happen with this virus last winter never
happened and this thing was very
interesting because there wasn't a
speech there wasn't an official
declaration there wasn't a parade there
wasn't even a banner it was Joe Biden
walking through a car show nonchalantly
talking to a TV show that aired his
comments five days five days later
saying Cove it's over yeah which is
absolutely crazy the one thing that the
article gets right is that it said it
will be a seasonal you know the winter
is coming and and it is seasonal the flu
it has a season lice cases go up in
September because all the kids are back
in school so when they're like well
we're headed towards a season of covid
it's like yeah we're also headed towards
the season of colds and a season of flu
because a lot of our illnesses are
seasonal let me let me read this quote
quote in a week that's Twin Towers right
it's a 9 11 week after week after week
said uh said Greg gonzalves an
epidemiologist at the Yale School of
Public Health
I just want to point out that people die
from like congenital heart failure and
from peanut allergies and other things
and it seems like the a covidian that's
the word right it's like a cult almost
these people are like hyper focused on
one thing it's like Bro Look at flu
deaths right I think they're about
probably half or so but if you're really
saying it's a 911 every week okay look
at car accidents like how many car
accidents are there every week so I want
to look it up yeah my point is you're
only talking about one thing Are We
Really Gonna shut down the world because
there's a thing that causes people to
die that's 107 000 people overdosed on
fentanyl last year and divided by 52
weeks that's 2057 per week so you know
that that's another thing that would
that is that is a twin towers every week
how many car accidents per year I've got
38 800 per year so what is that 38
000.50 was it two
um 107 000 died of just just fentanyl so
we're looking at 746 deaths a week in
2019 from car accidents in the United
States what about like heart failure
heart disease so we got we gotta shut it
all down you know we do that and well no
we gotta do it again heart disease and
to shut down the world for heart disease
being shut down the gym right shut down
all the gyms
and make them make them order Uber Eats
no I get it it's contagious per day so
it looks like covet is about seven times
as many uh deaths as there were car
accident deaths uh but what about heart
failure heart disease I'm still looking
for that what about obesity how many
people die every year from obesity I
think that that's not ever really the
cause it's that'll bring on something
else that will kill you yeah and it
tends to be a comorbidity
cancer deaths per year
300 000 people die every year due to
obesity whoa wow and it's an epidemic
they say obesity epidemic six thousand a
day 600 000 die of cancer every year in
America whoa I gotta say we had Drew
Pinsky on the show last Friday and he's
a you know a doctor Dr Drew and was
talking about paxilvid and how people
are having not breakthrough cases but uh
rebound cases which I think I don't know
exactly what a coveted rebound case is
are you guys it's on you test negative
and then you test positive again so I
think obesity yeah I'm sorry is that
covid is still here like I can feel it I
can feel my back in the same place where
I got really sick before I can see that
it's I can still sense it but I have an
immunity built up now to it oh so yeah
it's gonna be here like the flu virus
obesity is two 911s per week apparently
now we are going to be measuring deaths
in 911s because that's what and I I know
it's like it's kind of silly but they've
been doing that since the beginning of
coven like when covid deaths were really
high they were like 9 11 every day and
it's like this is a unit of measurement
I think Bill Maher made a joke about it
yeah amazing as a unit of how many Reich
stocks it's because you can point to the
911 people and see who supported them
who sympathizes with them and if you
don't believe in covet and if you don't
believe in vaccines and if you don't
believe in masking so you're you support
the terrorists and and in 911 and for
those of us who who remember when all
that happened were you even born with 9
11 to happen when 9 11 happened if you
were like well I think this is
ridiculous I was like oh so you want the
terrorists to win huh it's like no I
don't want the terrorists to win I just
don't think this is the right approach
well the CNN had a Ticker on their show
their producers were celebrating happy
that the numbers were going up because
of the more death the more fear the more
viewers that they had and this was
released by project Veritas I know
essentially they loved that ticker they
loved those numbers they loved
celebrating death and they loved the
trauma because essentially what we're
dealing with when we're dealing with
corporate media is a lot of trauma-based
mind control and this is again a lot of
sensationalism a lot of uh you know Doom
and Gloom a lot of severe winter illness
of death none of that happened they were
absolutely wrong this this day statement
is very convenient right before the
midterms and I think that has a lot more
to do with it than actual science that
was again bastardized from the very
beginning remember a lot a lot of people
pointed out including this show right
after Biden was inaugurated how the the
the CNN ticker death thing disappeared
from their screen right that was in the
bottom Chiron for for for a year and
like the week after Biden got in I was
like yeah we don't need to put that
number anymore even though more people
yeah even though more people died under
Biden which is a silly statistic right
but but it is a true one you know more
people died under Biden with coveted
than under Trump but they were like ah
we don't need to talk about statistics
anymore that's important you said with
covet and we we're gonna have to
continuously remind people that there's
a difference between dying with covid
and dying from covid because if you get
into a car accident you had covet in
your system you might die with covid
from a car accident but they'll still
clock you as a covet death because you
have covet in your system as opposed to
covert making you cough up blood no head
and they're like what did he die of
avoid that if covered no he doesn't have
a head they would say he died with
kovitz
which is very very you know that's
that's malicious in my opinion to say to
make the driver was decapitated uh but
he did have covered the passenger the
passenger was bifurcated right down the
middle but he had code so there were two
covet deaths because each half had covet
we found we found two income the head
was not wearing a mask oh my God I know
which proves it this is like a date from
this last three years I'm just still in
awe shock and awe man this is like our
eulogy for the pandemic yeah because I I
you know these these uh covidian people
they won't they don't want to give it up
they love being the Karen's wearing the
mass screaming at people shrieking but
it's done it's been done for a while but
this is it Joe Biden came out and said
it that's what we need now do you find
there's still people who are facing
mandates lockdowns things like that
restrictions it's time to start filing
lawsuits absolutely absolutely they're
still they're still teachers being fired
today today 850 unvaccinated teachers
and and Perez were fired from the New
York City education system there's still
an FDA emergency authorization for a
booster that was just tested on eight
mice there's still people losing their
jobs within the military because they
didn't comply with these mandates which
are which are absolutely nonsensical so
people are still being fired by this why
when the President says it's over Ian
you mentioned that people don't die of
obesity they die from something because
obviously that's called the comorbidity
and people are pointing out that's
literally how they Define covet deaths
as like people get sick and then they
die from comorbidities like was it like
90 some odd percent of people had some
kind of comorbidity and obesity was a
large component of huge so here's the
important factor is that obesity deaths
and covet deaths I imagine have a large
overlap yeah and and age also and then
they started hiding that data how many
people were over the age of 75 and it's
tragic right we don't want our old
people to die people forget the original
reason why the vaccines were rushed is
because it was supposed to save old
people and then for some reason it went
to let's get all this seniors vaccinated
to now you have to get your 15 year old
kid vaccinated I was like what I thought
this was for old people and the old
people if you look at it didn't have bad
reactions as much to the vaccine because
it was made for old people but for some
reason it disappeared like that that
thinking of I remember my parents were
happy because they were the ones at risk
dude the idea of vaccinating you to keep
Luke healthy is insane absolutely it's
like we live in the Middle Ages and
there's no and we're all like got
bacteria eating our skin alive then
maybe we would consider that I do want
to point out I think people need to
understand the the full context of what
happened inside of the pandemic
after a while we started seeing
different strains you know we get to
like Omicron or whatever and it's
getting weaker and it's weaker it's like
people need to understand the alpha
strain was really scary the the scar
tissue and damage in people's lungs we
had Dr giron you mentioned the spike
protein was was causing microvascular
damage and then it was inhibiting
nutrients and you know oxygen stuff to
get into parts of the body in the early
days of covid you could see the scans of
people's lungs it was really really bad
that's kind of you know yeah I don't
know I think we got Omicron is that what
we got when we got sick
I think it was Delta but there was also
a lot of malpractice inside of the
hospitals that were doing things that
they later found out was absolutely
wrong especially when it came to
drugging a lot of the patients and then
giving them particular medicines that
gave them organ fire we were talking
about malpractice or are you saying
error
um you could I don't know how you want
to I guess categorize it but but there
was a lot of mistakes made early on in
the hospitals that's what I mean to say
like we didn't know what we were doing
like
there's a difference between a doctor
screwing up and us being like this is
the best thing we could think of yeah
but I got I gotta say like I think
policy wise there's a total abject
failure but I thought you should have
been fired immediately that's Trump's
fault but any criticism was
automatically censored any anyone
speaking up was automatically shut down
and there was practices that were done
that that people saw as a mistake
especially when it came to the
ventilators people were saying hey maybe
we shouldn't be doing this maybe we
shouldn't be uh you know knocking
patients out and giving them drugs that
give them organ failure so their bodies
can't fight it off maybe we shouldn't be
incubating them and and that was a big
argument that should have happened
publicly but it didn't and the policies
continued on to the detriment of a lot
of early patients thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
elusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there